hello everyone and welcome to what the
fragment so I'm Adam Powell I'm a member
of the android framework team
specifically on the UI toolkit but i've
spent a fair amount of time with
fragments over the years here and
hopefully we can go over some
interesting information here so the
first thing that people tend to ask is
why fragments there's a lot of
information out on the web as people
have used the api gotten kind of
familiar with it and in some ways kind
of gotten bitten by it there's a lot of
complexity there and in fact some
members of the community have put
together a few diagrams of just how
complex the fragment lifecycle can be if
you combine it with the full activity
lifecycle as well so you can start up at
the top here and we keep going and
there's some more whoo ok well we got to
the end so the blurriness that you're
seeing here isn't just because it's a
low res version of the image it's just
your eyes glazing over as you try and
take all of this in and this is kind of
your reaction after reading over it so
by fragment if this is kind of the
reaction that everybody's had over the
last few years out in the developer
community why is it still something that
we're pushing or promoting as some as a
way to build your applications well to
start with that we'll go over just kind
of a little bit of history about where
fragments came from so some of you might
have seen a Google+ post by Dianne
Hackborn the set there this past weekend
where she went into some detail about
the Android component model and how it's
really not intended to impose a lot of
higher-level architecture on your
applications instead it's really just
meant to be a series of smarter entry
points so in a traditional program that
you might have seen in classes or so on
and so forth you start from a main
function and you run to the end and you
might start a message loop in the middle
there and what activities really give
you to start with is just kind of a
smarter entry point the place where the
system can send you other messages about
what's going on to your application and
these are just turned into callbacks on
an object
instead so there were some other goals
kind of in the design of activities as
well which one of those is that apps
always stay in the state where you left
them so in order to do that you have
this well-defined activity life cycle
and a compact state representation that
you can use so the process can die come
back later restore from that state all
of this is stuff that you're probably
familiar with also apps can call other
apps to complete a task in the form of
activity is called with intent and each
one of those flows is represented as one
of these encapsulated units in the form
of these activities so overtime
activities just started getting big and
complex and and basically the way that
you deal with complexity is that you
factor out smaller pieces so that you
can compose them back in the pre Android
3.0 days we had this thing called local
activity manager that could work in
concert with a tab host widget that you
can see here in the old gingerbread
dialer app so each one of these pieces
in each one of these tabs actually
contained a full activity so that kind
of gave some some weird weird pieces of
the code there in terms of how how the
code would interact there are ideas in
the activity lifecycle that just really
don't make sense of this kind of
composed model and then this happened
and we're not going to talk about that
so larger screens happen and larger
screens mean larger problems so we have
this idea of how do you want to present
these multiple small screens worth of UI
that you may have already built in an
existing application and then sort of
scale that out across other screens is
there sort of a smaller unit of
composition that you could use for that
and so that other unit of composition
spoilers is fragments so this was
introduced around honeycomb to try to
solve some of these problems the first
one of these goals though was really
just to break up these giant activity
classes and this is a problem that
happens whether you're dealing just with
small phone screens or if you're trying
to scale across many different screen
sizes and it's just kind of natural that
as app complexity grows so does the
complexity of these kind of big entry
points that can kind of
to be these God objects if you're not
careful we also kind of wanted to fix
some of these problems with local
activity manager for when you do compose
them in these smaller constructs so you
have lots of these abstractions at the
activity level that just don't work well
when you start composing it this way
these are usually things that aren't
quite as well covered is like the core
activity state diagram but they're all
cases that still need to be handled in a
general-purpose solution one of the
other things that we wanted to do with
fragments was to encapsulate navigation
state so the state of your fragments can
represent the full state of your
activity in a way that can be preserved
through actor through state save and
restore through a process death so we
have things like an activity local back
stack which some people find useful and
some people don't but managed dialogues
was one of the other things that this
really tried to address dialog fragment
is something that a lot of people do use
at this point and it's because you
basically get the state restoration for
free if you rotate the screen or go
through any other sorts of config
changes back before fragments this was
handled by just kind of this first-class
facility that was provided by activities
where you refer to a dialogue by its ID
there's this whole other creation
process involved in terms of like yes I
want to create the dialogue with this ID
we would persist that ID and try to
build everything back up from scratch
and that ended up just being very
one-off and kind of awkward to work with
and the final goal that was probably the
most obvious in terms of how we pitched
the API when it was first released is
this idea of decomposing these
master/detail UIs so if you have two
screens that on a phone might look
something like this where you've got a
list of conversations as well as the
actual conversation itself as you drill
down by tapping into it use the back
button to get back to where you were
before in another configuration you
could take what's essentially the same
code and have it look like this so this
is something that you might be familiar
with from a lot of you is that you've
seen here and since then we kept
building on it so we had view pager and
the fragment pager adapter which a lot
of people still kind of think is the way
to use a view pager
because we don't have a stock adapter
for dealing with just bear views so
we've got loaders which allow you to do
similar things of persisting some sort
of a request across configuration
changes keep it going whether or not the
lifecycle might otherwise interrupt ian
lake has a great post up on medium about
this that all you should go read if you
haven't as well and then we also had
this idea of child fragments so i mean
if you can nest one level deep in terms
of putting fragments inside an activity
well why can't you put fragments inside
a fragment so that was an idea that had
a lot of support in terms of a lot of
developers were requesting this both
within google and external developers as
well and it got added i think sometime
around the jellybean timeframe so how
did it work out i mean some of you kind
of already know the answer to this
question but these are sort of what we
took as stewards of the api as some of
the lessons from fragments so the first
problem is that fragments are so general
that they become really difficult to
explain to people so is it just a pain
of a UI like in the gmail example is it
something like dialog fragments and
something that to deal with managed
dialogues or is it something different
altogether like you can still have
headless fragments that can act
completely independently of anything
else and we didn't give a whole lot of
guidance in terms of how to use these
things because we kind of felt like we
didn't want to be too prescriptive about
it and that ended up really hurting us
so of course the idea of even more
lifecycle to manage was really kind of
the killer here and the bugs really
didn't help this is really what killed a
lot of people whenever I've talked to
whenever I talk to developers about what
they would change about the fragment API
or what problems they have in using the
fragment API a lot of times what happens
is that you build up a fragment
transaction you commit it and then
something works completely differently
from how you expect it's not
particularly intuitive some of these
things and it might kind of remove the
entire point of a bunch of code that you
just spent a lot of time writing
so this was another thing that caused a
lot of misconceptions
I mean fragments they're just kind of
like views right I mean you can stick
this fragment tag in one of your layout
files inflate it and you get a fragment
for free
in hindsight the fragment tag was this
great piece of syntactic sugar that
really confused people a lot more than
it helps in terms of just general
education so this immediately made
people think that fragment equals view
and that this is on the same level of
abstraction so if we kind of know where
things went off the rails then you know
how might we start trying to use
fragments a little bit more effectively
well the first thing to keep in mind
here is that fragments are roughly
equivalent to an activity in terms of
the level of abstraction that they act
on there composable entry points and
their lifecycle and inputs are really
controlled by their surroundings they
optionally manage a UI presentation and
they're really kind of part of the
whatever in Model View whatever in terms
of the architectural patterns that you
may be using within your application
they're not views themselves and they're
really not meant to be seriously they're
not just fancy view groups fragments
implement you eyes just by using views
they compose views they wire things up
to views in order to do something more
interesting and this really kind of
comes down to a core idea that isn't
communicated all that widely that we
kind of keep this idea of an abstraction
hierarchy across the different packages
in the framework the higher level
packages are things like Android app
whereas the views and widgets are
further down the stack and what this
means in practice in terms of the
organization of code within the android
framework is that anything at a higher
level can import anything from a lower
level but not the other way around and
if you go looking through AOSP you'll
probably find a couple of places where
we mess this up and yes we know it we're
sorry but overall it's managed to be a
pretty good way of organizing some of
this stuff and making sure that things
keep keep a level of responsibility
that's kind of appropriate for that type
of
opponent so an example of this is that
you might have a fragment that depends
on view onclicklistener
in order to implement that interface
this is an example of a fragment just
kind of applying policy to a series of
views that's using Emma so while
fragments can depend on views and
implement the interface is exposed by
those of use it's important to remember
that the views have no knowledge of
fragments that fragments really kind of
sit as the policy layer above whatever
UI that you've built visually and out of
the structure that is used to generate
input event so on and so forth so really
they're kind of a glue component in this
case they provide coordination of these
different view components or even of
other components within your app they
allow you to wire up the view events the
input events that you may be generating
from those of use and tell them
something interesting to do and all of
that ends up being driven by a knowledge
of the external life cycle what's going
on outside the app what's going on
outside the context of that particular
fragment or activity so this is
something that others have definitely
said and I will totally echo here don't
use a fragment when just a composite
custom view group or even just a layout
resource that you can use in an include
tag will do the job better a lot of
times people use this as a point of
where they can pivot where they can
decide what type of UI to show based on
other conditions and between the
resource system and custom view groups
you can solve that problem without
getting into life cycle constructs the
real question to ask when you're talking
about using a custom view group or a
fragment in these cases is does it
implement mechanism or does it implement
policy is it an isolated widget that
generates its own input events and these
might be really complex as well I mean
we've got some things in more recent
versions of the support library like
coordinator layout
that are able to impose very complex
behaviors on their child views things
that you can push and pull and move
around swipe to dismiss so on and so
forth
but all of those essentially are still
just the user acting on the UI you might
be able to swipe a snack bar away you
might be able to click a apply button on
a snack bar and a coordinator layout or
something but what that actually means
to the application is policy that's
imposed by some other component and
that's more where fragments sitting in
the layering so we also can't talk about
fragments and dealing with some of the
Associated complexity without talking
about saved State so the navigational
state of your application is partially
composed by the fragments that are
currently attached to it these may have
changed over time contents may have
shifted during flight so on and so forth
where if you have something like master
detail UIs then you might have a very
different fragment that you're showing
if you were drilled into item a versus
drilled into item B in that list and
that's something that ideally you don't
want to have to track yourself in terms
of other state as it gets restored as
your process dies you come back into it
so on and so forth so that means that
setup of fragments is conditional and
this is another one of those kind of
weird things that everybody sees when
they first start working with fragments
well why am i why am i doing this extra
check here when I'm setting up this
initial state and that's partially
because the fragments are going to be
restored as part of that on create call
now this has historically gotten a
little bit weird in that if you're
dealing with child fragments when that
reinflates really wasn't consistent with
the way that it happens with fragments
that are attached to activities now over
the last several months we've really
kind of dope dived into the fragment
api's and tried to clean up a lot of
these cases where the behavior was just
unexpected or inconsistent because these
are the things that really made
everybody hate the API to start with so
as of Android N and support library
version 24 which is available as part of
the preview SDK right now child
fragments are just as with
activity attached fragments they're
consistently reinf lated during the
super dot on create call that you make
within your own code so that way after
you make that call you know that those
fragments that were restored from
instance state are attached to your
activity you can do frying fragment by
tag and actually expect to find it there
you won't end up with duplicates when
you try to deal with that case thank you
so that alone makes things a whole lot
easier to deal with hmm the illegal
State exception which one we'll get to
in a minute okay so again we keep coming
back to this idea of fragment States in
that giant diagram so how do we just
stop worrying and love the life cycle
here because every one of these stages
of the life cycle really does represent
a significant event that can happen to
your application and just because we
have a lot of them there doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to care
about all of them all the time a lot of
fragments that you'll write will only
implement a couple of these methods but
just having all the options there can be
really overwhelming when you're just
looking at documentation so you know
that big flowchart like I couldn't tell
you everything on that big flowchart at
once off the top of my head either but
the nice part about this is that you
really don't have to hold all of that in
your head at once because even though
those interactions look very complex
really the fragment life cycle is driven
by what's essentially a single integer
value so this is straight out of the
fragment source code where we have these
six states that fragments move between
and the nice thing about these states is
that this isn't like a completely
connected graph of states this is linear
so when fragments move from one state to
another they move through all of the
other states in turn dispatching the
appropriate methods to the fragment to
deal with those life cycle events so
this leads to something really kind of
convenient which is that all you need to
think about is what invariants do I need
to enforce for my new state you can keep
your thinking very much constrained to
each one of these individual life cycle
methods so that you don't have to worry
about the state of the entire
our application in aggregate when you're
dealing with this more importantly you
can say what minimum state will this
component be in or what can I count on
since again the fragment states are
linear so if you know that you're up all
the way at the resumed state you know
that you've been through all of the
other methods and this is one of those
things that kind of seems obvious in
hindsight but again as you're looking
through the smorgasbord of methods that
you can override on fragment itself
sometimes this kind of gets lost in the
noise so let's go ahead and talk about a
few other things talk about one bug fix
that was pretty significant which is
that the child fragment manager state is
guaranteed after the super dot on create
call now this is subtly different from
what I said earlier about restoring
fragments from instance state because
there was this really kind of a fun bug
that happens so how many of you use
execute pending transactions for some
part of your work with fragments or have
tried in the past okay keep your hand up
if you ended up regretting doing that
during a debugging session later okay
yeah that's a pretty close match for
some of that so execute pending
transactions is this really handy method
on the fragment manager that tells it
okay all of those things that you've
queued up with fragment transaction
commit do all of them right now all of
them that you've got pending and that's
got a couple of kind of interesting
issues with it that we'll get into in a
minute but one of the interesting things
about that is that you have expectations
after that call specifically if you've
committed one or more fragment
transactions before that then you expect
those fragments that you've committed in
that transaction to be brought up to a
particular state in the life cycle
usually matching the container well it
turns out that that wasn't actually how
things worked some of you probably found
this out and this again came down to
this idea of what happens with child
fragments you probably noticing a bit of
a theme here so what would happen
instead is that the child fragment
manager itself wouldn't be brought up to
the new state until long after
the parents on create' return so all of
these invariants that should make it a
lot more easy to to reason about your
program especially when you're saying
that hey resolve everything right now
execute pending transactions well all
that just kind of went out the window
so that made things a lot more difficult
that's now fixed so again you know that
you don't have to worry about that after
the call to super dot on create so
execute pending transactions had another
kind of problem as well which was that
it makes everything happen right now and
the issue with that is that different
parts of your program might be
committing fragment transactions at
different times so as soon as you say
execute pending transaction in one piece
you may have just caused a side effect
that it affects some other library that
you imported that uses fragments and you
didn't even know about it so we went
ahead and we added a commit now a method
to fragment transaction which basically
does the same thing but really kind of
what you wanted instead which is no just
this transaction commit this one right
now this does have one particular
limitation which is that you can't deal
with fragments on the back stack if you
use commit now just because if you have
other fragment transactions pending you
don't kind of want to create inversions
in your back stack in terms of when
those really apply we also added a
fragment on attach fragment method to
match the fragment activity and activity
on attach fragment method this is kind
of useful when you want to go ahead and
configure a fragment as it's being
attached to its parent if you want to do
any sort of injection of dependencies if
you want to do any sort of any sort of
wiring up of listeners within that local
activity for other events that it might
publish this is a pretty good time to do
it except there really wasn't a good
place to do this with child fragments
before this was something that was
entirely skipped you couldn't even do it
in the parent activity if you wanted to
because it was only ever called on the
parent activity if and only if the
fragment was attached directly to the
activity not any of the children
so a few other notes that are kind of
useful here this is one that some
developers ran into fairly recently as
we fix some other bugs around fragment
transitions which is that to obtain the
state of a fragment transition we have
to interrogate the fragment we have to
call a method on the fragment to get the
transition values and what it should do
but in order to make that make sense to
that fragment we have to bring the
fragment up to the created state before
we ask it about the transition so what
that means in effect is that we have to
bring some fragments up to the created
state before they become fully attached
or before they replace whatever fragment
that they were replacing before so this
is one of those things that's good to be
aware of don't assume that just because
your fragment goes through the attach
and create steps that all of the other
surrounding State about a fragment
transaction has necessarily happened yet
again this is something that you want to
make sure that you keep your thinking
within a fragment implementation scoped
just to that fragment make sure that
it's not trying to take on
responsibilities outside of itself and
again they really work best when they
can behave as isolated from their
surroundings one of the things that I
see people do a lot is that when a
fragment becomes attached and again just
because you have problems with state
restoration of more complex objects it's
pretty common for people to say okay
well when I get attached to my activity
I'm going to go ahead grab the activity
and go fishing I'll go ahead and check
her out if I can find other fragments
other sibling fragments by tag grab any
other sort of associated information
from that activity down cast it to a
specific type so on and so forth and
while this ends up being pretty
convenient it also means that those
fragments suddenly become a whole lot
less reusable elsewhere and while you
may not care about that right from the
outset it is one of those things that
tends to come back and bite people later
on and then they wonder you know why
didn't we have some other facility to to
do this to do a cleaner injection of the
dependencies on and so forth
okay so that was a lot of information
really fast and some of it probably
didn't answer a lot of the core
questions that you may have had coming
in here which is you know I really don't
like this API that I've used why should
like change my mind why should why
should I go back and give it another
chance and really the core issue here is
that apps aren't getting any smaller so
when you start working especially across
large teams and across code bases that
have lasted for a very long time
architectural patterns don't end up
being universal and this is part of what
Diane was trying to get to in her post
over this weekend as well if you have a
very long-lived codebase then what was
popular and the obvious way that
everyone should build their apps back
when the codebase was started isn't
necessarily true when you're maintaining
it years down the road so one solution
to that is to try to create standard
smarter components so how many of you
have taken a look at integration steps
for some library for Android and you see
something that looks kind of like what's
on the slide here okay go ahead and add
this snippet Iran create this other
thing to your on start this one to on
stop I'm pretty sure that some of our
own libraries from Google have these
types of instructions as well things
where you need to call some particular
method from some part of your lifecycle
and really that just makes these
integrations really kind of messy so
instead of that well we could just have
well add this fragment instead and we'll
go ahead and take care of those extra
lifecycle steps and that suddenly makes
that a lot more reusable and a lot less
error-prone and the nice thing about
this is really that Oh or even better
you can just use one of these tags I
mean even though we had issues around
kind of general education around
fragments on what they could do it's
really powerful to be able to say here's
a piece of my UI I just want to drop
this completely self-contained component
here and then not think about it to be
able to just configure it possibly from
other XML attributes as specified there
and then just let that component do its
thing
so the idea here is to really try and
provide these single points of
high-level integration that everyone can
use and that last part is really key
again not everyone is going to be using
the same architectural patterns that
your app does and your own app may not
use those patterns the same way over
time either but fragments are kind of
uniquely positioned here and that's
because fragments really closely mirror
that activity lifecycle there are a few
differences here and there but by and
large like as you're thinking about
invariance to enforce within a fragment
they really match what you do with
activities as part of that core entry
point idea for Android components so
that means that essentially they can sit
below that level of abstraction of your
higher-level architecture that you
impose upon your application and that
makes them reusable as components in the
same way that views are reusable to
fragments so when fragments are
communicating with the rest of the world
you really need to be careful about the
types of configuration dependencies that
you end up creating you again this is
this comes down to that issue of are you
going fishing in your parent activity or
in your parent fragment for that matter
for other dependencies and re is that
fragment going to blow up if those
things aren't there are those
dependencies documented how is someone
who's using that fragment necessarily
going to know that that's a requirement
now in a codebase within a particular
team again this may not be a problem but
as things grow over time the we tend to
see a lot of these patterns show up and
that means that you really do need to
consider your audience as you're
building these things if you're building
libraries the answer to this is going to
be a lot different from if you're just
building another screen within your own
application in your own application sure
go ahead and take a dependency on some
internal component I mean it might help
it might hurt but at the very least
you're not passing this out to the rest
of the wider world and also if you are
offering the ability to use fragments
that are the standalone drop-in
components the on inflate method is
sorely underused in some of these so
this lets you do the same thing that you
do with views specify specify some
configuration attributes
might be something like an API key it
might be something like any other sort
of information that you need to pass to
that fragment as arguments but you can
do it without having to muck around with
it in code necessarily during that
initial startup phase of your
application because again you want to
try to have one integration point with
these things thank you all for coming